reeves en réanimation alors que d'autres
quittent le service est donc c'est le
besoin de prise en charge quotidien
c'est évidemment un indicateur important
qui permet de percevoir la tension dans
les établissements de santé et le besoin
de mobiliser toutes les ressources
humaines et logistiques
il n'y a jamais eu autant de malades en
réanimation en france pour une seule
pathologie mêmes pour toutes les
pathologies puisque vous savez que nous
avons doublé la capacité de réanimation
au niveau national quatorze mille huit
personnes sont guéris sortie de
l'hôpital c'est 1582 plus ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle et il faut y ajouter
toutes les personnes qui sont guéris en
ville je vous ai dit hier que plus de
50000 personnes avaient été probablement
infectées en cours de semaine douze des
90 mille personnes en semaine 13 toutes
ces personnes qui n'ont plus de
symptômes sont aujourd'hui considérés
comme guéris
en ce qui concerne la surveillance
syndromique en population les services
d'accueil des urgences ont renseigné
3668 passage hier ses 17% de leur
activité totale nous observons après ses
passages 39% d'hospitalisation et 3%
ce passage direct en réanimation elle
souhaite médecins nous fait remonter
1038 intervention contre 1217 pour la
journée précédente pour une suspicion de
kovy de cours de la journée 7 19% de
leur activité totale enfin les
laboratoires de ville continue à
pratiquer des tests 40 3634 tests dont
12 1624 positif soit 29% de positivité
vous le savez nous sommes très attentifs
à la situation dans les établissements
sociaux médico-sociaux nos ehpad
l'accueil évidemment au quotidien de nos
personnes âgées une personne vulnérable
de nous personne en situation de
handicap
plus de 3000 établissements ses 66% des
ehpad et 34%
d'autres établissements médico-sociaux
plus de 3000 établissements ont déjà
signalé un épisode concernant un ou
plusieurs cas de co vide
à santé publique france donc par une
application spécifique sur un portail de
signalements et par des données qui nous
ont remonté aussi par les agences
régionales de santé les établissements
continuent de jour en jour à saisir
leurs données dans ce portail pour
aboutir à un recueil que nous souhaitons
exhaustif l'ensemble des signalements
aujourd'hui correspond à un total de
dix-sept 1827 cas de kobe de 19
confirmés ou possible depuis le début de
l'épidémie
le dispositif de signalement poursuit
donc sa montée en charge
nous sommes évidemment aussi très
soucieux du bilan de cette épidémie
meurtrière du bilan des décès
première source d'information la
mortalité hospitalière
depuis le 1er mars nous déplorons 5091
décès 83 % de ces décès ont lieu chez
des personnes de plus de 70 ans dont 13
décès en outre-mer 8 en guadeloupe 3 en
martinique et deux à mayotte
au cours des dernières 24 heures ce sont
donc 5 188 décès de plus qui ont été
enregistrés en milieu hospitalier
471 décès avaient été signalés la veille
nous observons aussi la mortalité en
établissements médico sociaux en ehpad
et à ce jour nous avons une remontée
d'informations 2416 décès survenus au
sein de ces établissements
depuis le début de l'épidémie de plus en
plus d'établissements font aujourd'hui
des remontées systématique ce qui
explique ce nombre important est
fortement augmenté par rapport à celui
d'hier ce n'est pas une augmentation
dans la journée c'est juste une
augmentation des remontées
d'informations puisque de plus en plus
d'établissements participent à cette
remontée d'informations en additionnant
les décès survenus en milieu hospitalier
depuis le début de l'épidémie et ceux
rapportés par les établissements médico
sociaux depuis le début d'épidémie je
parle bien du 1er mars
nous déplorons donc ce soit 6500 sept
décès enfin nous suivons l'évolution de
la mortalité toutes causes confondues
à l'échelon national par la mobilisation
de l'état civil de l'insee de santé
publique france l'excès de décès par
rapport à la mortalité attendue au cours
d'un mois de mars se renforce pour la
semaine 13 du 23 au 28 mars et atteint
désormais 23% à l'échelon régional
l'excès de mortalité par rapport à la
mortalité attendue en semaine 13 est
important dans cinq régions grand test
île de france bourgogne franche comté
haute france et auvergne rhône-alpes et
à l'échelon départemental en semaine 13
26 départements présentent un excès de
mortalité par rapport à la mortalité
attendue ses excès s'observe
principalement chez des personnes de
plus de 65 ans
en ce qui concerne les résultats des
tests de recherche du virus par pcr
nous avons désormais 64 1338 cas
confirmés soit 5333 cas de plus cette
épidémie de kobe 19 est totalement
inédite avec vous l'avez vu des milliers
de cas très graves et des milliers de
morts
nous devons donc tous respecté les
consignes de confinement actuellement en
vigueur
surtout en cette période de vacances qui
débutent et poursuivre l'application
rigoureuse et quotidienne des gestes
barrières
ces mesures sont absolument nécessaires
pour combattre activement la diffusion
du virus
ce n'est qu'en limitant drastiquement
ses déplacements et en évitant
absolument les déplacements longue
distance qui vous met en contact avec le
virus ou qui vous font à porter le virus
dans une zone moins touchés en
respectant la distanciation social ces
fameux cette fameuse distance d'un mètre
que nous arrivons tous à protéger nos
proches
ce soir plus que jamais rester chez vous
si vous voulez sauver des vies
concernant les capacités de réanimation
nous sommes évidemment très vigilant au
nombre de lits disponibles pour
accueillir des patients supplémentaires
qui sont pris en charge chaque jour
ce chiffre est donc le reflet de la
tension spital hier dans les services de
réanimation du besoin de mobilisation
totale des équipes soignantes vous
pouvez le voir sur ce graphique nous
observons nous observons toujours un
solde positif mais moindres un besoin
toujours croissant de lits dans un
contexte qui reste extrêmement critique
et les équipes sont au maximum de leur
mobilisation
depuis des jours en ce qui concerne
enfin les transferts nous veillons
depuis le premier jour à offrir les
meilleurs soins possibles à chaque
patient notamment les patients qui
nécessitent une réanimation
cet objectif permanent nous a conduits
au nom de la solidarité nationale à
opérer des transferts de patients en
intra régional mais aussi entre régions
d'une région très attention vers une
région plus épargnés vous pouvez le voir
sur cette carte des transferts cinq
opérations de transfert ont permis de
déplacer 115 patients aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france 47 patients ont été
transférés par voie aérienne vers les
pays de loire
dix patients ont atterri en centre val
de loire 52 patients franciliens ont été
déplacés vers la normandie par voie
terrestre et aérienne dans la région
grand est
six patients ont été évacués vers
l'occitanie grâce à une nouvelle
opération militaire mort fait au nom de
la solidarité nationale et européenne
des transferts transfrontaliers à
destination du luxembourg de la suisse
de l'autriche de l'allemagne ont été
réalisés ou sont encore en cours cent
soixante quinze patients de la région
grand est ont bénéficié de ces
transferts d'autres opérations sont
prévues pour soulager nos hôpitaux et
nos équipes soignantes
je peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
de nouvelles opérations militaires
morphée et de tgv médicalisés sont
planifiés pour transférer des patients
du grand est et de l'île de france
grâce à la mobilisation totale de
l'ensemble des moyens de l'état
de la sncf du service de santé des
armées et de la sécurité civile ce sont
500 6 patients lourds en réanimation qui
ont été transférés vers des régions - en
tension ce nombre est amené à progresser
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent
à la demi-heure à la demande du
ministère de la santé des transferts de
personnels soignants au profit des
établissements de santé d'ile-de-france
ont été organisées ces dernières 48
heures depuis les régions paca occitanie
auvergne rhône-alpes et nouvelle
aquitaine il s'agit de plus de 200
personnes 194 déjà sur place 32 ans
court d'affectation ce sont des médecins
anesthésistes réanimateurs des
infirmiers anesthésistes
les régions bretagne et normandie ont
également mis à disposition des
professionnels de santé de leur région
au profit de l'île de france
il s'agit notamment de trois médecins
anesthésistes et de 36 infirmiers un
dispositif similaire d'entre aide de
solidarité est en place pour le grand
est qui a déjà reçu le renfort d'une
vingtaine de réservistes sanitaire des
médecins anesthésistes des infirmiers
anesthésistes et infirmiers ainsi que 24
personnels soignants dont douze médecins
anesthésistes réanimateurs et 12
infirmiers anesthésistes qui nous
viennent de nouvelles aquitaine une très
belle solidarité donc des professionnels
de santé entre eux et des régions entre
elles vous le savez nous poussons aussi
très fortement la recherche clinique
nous la soutenons depuis le début et
nous faisons en sorte que ces essais
cliniques et lieu très rapidement dans
l'intérêt des patients
deux essais cliniques dénommé discovery
et cory minots sont en cours de
recrutement très actifs et plus de 600
patients sont déjà inclus et reçoivent
donc un certain nombre de molécules
testées huit autres essais ont débuté ou
vont débuter très prochainement près de
30 études thérapeutiques sont en cours
d'instruction pour autorisation rapide
l'activité de recherche clinique et donc
intense sur notre territoire et j'en
profite pour remercier tous les
investigateurs tous les médecins qui
inclut et les comités de protection des
personnes ainsi que l' agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament qui se
mobilisent pour expertiser en urgence
dans des délais très contraint tous les
projets qui leur sont
oumy les soir et le week end compris je
tiens ce soir comme vous le faites tous
les soirs à remercier l'ensemble des
soignants de notre pays dont
l'engagement est sans faille face à
cette crise dure longue exceptionnel
sans répit ils fournissent des efforts
surhumains de jour comme de nuit
absolument remarquable pour sauver des
vies celle de nos proches celles de nos
familles celle de nos amis notre
gratitude est à l'image de leur
dévouement total
je vous remercie une question de l'
agence italienne en deçà cats ont
envisagé de faire en france si l'om est
change de politique concernant les
masques et en recommande le port
strictes alors comme vous le savez nous
avons en france comme en europe
finalement une tradition du port de
masques qui est bien connu des français
les soignants portent des masques en cas
de daktari sq et les malades portent des
masques les patients qui ont une
tuberculose porto des matches et ça
reste un usage très hospitaliers et pour
les françaises et les français qui
fréquentent les hôpitaux
d'habitude on ne voit pas de masse même
dans les couloirs des hôpitaux c'est
vraiment un soin au sein de la chambre
du malade il y a les traditions de port
de masques en asie qui sont très
différentes pour ceux qui ont eu la
chance de voyager les asiatiques ont
pris cette habitude de porter des
masques quand ils sont malades
ce que nous encourageons d'ailleurs dans
nos campagnes notamment pour la grippe
quand on a la grippe on encourage le
port de masques et donc on avait encore
cette approche port de masques pour les
malades
la france que vous le savez a fait le
choix de produire sur son territoire
national certes des masques pour les
soignants certes des masques pour les
malades mais aussi des masques dits
alternatifs et donc cette production est
en cours de 2 d'augmentation massive et
l'idée que les français puissent avoir
accès s'il le souhaite à ce support de
masques de protection un peu différente
des usages on va dire quotidien il ya
même la possibilité de fabriquer son
masque et on voit que l'innovation est
extraordinaire en france puisque des
infirmiers ont créé leur propre masque
avec des visières des masques permettant
de voir le la bouche que de voir le
sourire donc on voit qu'il ya une
créativité remarquable
tous ces masques permettent de se
protéger effectivement dû des postillons
de se protéger quand on est en face à
face puisque je rappelle que les
transmissions gouttelettes se font en
face à face à moins d'un mètre et donc
si nous avons l'accès à des masses que
nous encourageons effectivement le grand
public s'ils le souhaitent à porter des
masques en particulier ses masques
alternatif qui sont en cours de
production
alors une autre question sur les masques
à ses proches de france info cette fois
l'académie de médecine via le professeur
mattei conseil le port d'un masque à la
population ne serait ce que pour les
faits dit de mémoire un effet
psychologique afin que les personnes qui
sortent se souviennent qu elles doivent
prendre des précautions
il dit que les masque en tissu fabriqué
à domicile suffisent dans ce cadre que
pensez vous de cette position donc du
professeur mattéï et de l'académie
métier alors effectivement c'est une
position de l'académie de médecine qui
est qui a été rendu public aujourd'hui
qui est très intéressante puisque
l'académie nous soutient d'abord en
réservant les masques chirurgicaux et
des masques ffp2 à une une activité de
soins et ça ça a été très clair et en
rappelant l'importance des mesures
barrières
là aussi l'académie insiste sur le fait
que le lavage des mains tout ce qu'on a
appris ce re la façon de tout c'est de
jeter son mouchoir à usage unique
c'est très important et ça doit être
maintenu que les mesures de confinement
que les mesures barrières lui paraissent
justifiés mais effectivement la notion
maintenant d'accès du de l'ensemble du
public à un masque grand public ou
alternatif peut être encouragé et
effectivement c'est ce que je viens de
vous dire il y a une production
française de ce type de masque et donc
on va peut-être voir des changements de
comportement au sein des foyers français
si les français veulent s'équiper de ces
types de masques alternatif sans oublier
qu'ils ne remplacent pas les gestes
barrière le lavage des mains et la
distanciation sociale une question du
quotidien du médecin
une ordonnance en date du 1er avril
permet au médecin du travail de
pratiquer dépistage à partir de quand et
parle-t-on ici des tests sérologiques
alors aujourd'hui on parle vraiment du
dépistage de la maladie et donc nous
nous encourageons désormais
effectivement l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
pouvoir pratiquer ce test un test que je
vous rappelle est un test assez facile
on papa de prises de sang en parle d' un
écouvillon qui est introduit au fond des
fosses nasales jusqu'aux caves hommes
pour faire un petit frottis par un coton
tige de la muqueuse nasale donc que
c'est un test assez facile qui n'est pas
agressif qui n'est pas invasif qui n'est
pas à risque et donc si tous les
professionnels de santé peuvent faire ce
test si tous les laboratoires peuvent
effectivement technique et ce test on
favorise l'accès au dépistage et là on
parle de dépistage on ne parle pas
encore de l'accès à la sérologique est
une autre technique et qui n'a d'intérêt
que quand le virus a circulé que l'on
cherche à savoir qu elle l immunité en
population une question de seignosse on
nous dit que le but du confinement et de
limiter l'arrivée en nombre des malades
aux urgences pourquoi ne pas débuter le
déconfinement quand les unités de
réanimation auront un grand nombre de
lits disponibles
alors effectivement l'objectif principal
de du confinement s'est pas d'enfermer
les gens chez eux c'est d'éviter au
maximum les contacts
si nous avions une à moyens
extraordinaires d'éviter les contacts
entre nous en ayant une vie normale on
l'appliquerait sauf que c'est très
compliqué parce que vous voyez bien
qu'au quotidien
quand on est dans un magasin quand on
est au travail quand on est dans un
transport
on ne peut pas appliquer en permanence
gestes barrières à la distanciation
sociale parce qu'il ya trop de monde
parce qu'on n'a pas cette habitude et
parce qu'il faut de toute façon de tenir
compte du fait que on doit changer nos
comportements favoriser le télétravail
supprimer les réunions présentiel il ya
énormément de choses à faire et donc on
voit bien que là encore nous devons
profondément changer nos comportements
nous devons en priorité aujourd'hui
éviter des morts évitées des passages en
réanimation je vous ai dit que ce soir
il n'y avait jamais eu autant de malades
en réanimation en france les équipes ont
poussé les murs elles ont créé des lits
elles ont récupéré des renforts humains
elles ont récupéré du matériel c est
juste extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé
en france
et tant mieux je crois que les français
peuvent vraiment remercier leurs équipes
soignantes
mais le pire serait qu effectivement
qu'il y à re lâchement aujourd'hui est
que dans huit jours ou dans quinze jours
il y encore plus de malades en
réanimation
donc c'est vraiment ça que nous voulons
éviter aujourd'hui nous n'avons même pas
encore évalué l'impact du confinement
que nous attendons dans les deux ou
trois jours qui viennent de commencer à
voir
évolution dans cette courbe et donc il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour parler du
déconfinement parce que j'ai des
confinement si nous ne respectons pas
tout ce que je viens de dire en termes
de gestes barrières de dissension
sociale et d'éviter les contacts se
traduirait par un afflux massif de
nouveaux malades et ce serait vraiment
une catastrophe puisque notre objectif
est vraiment tous ensemble d'éviter ces
cas graves et d'éviter tous les décès
une question de vl médias les besoins en
dons du sang et en plaquettes
augmente-t-il fortement avec le
développement de l'épidémie
le niveau des réserves dans ce domaine
vous inquiète-t-il nous surveillons de
très près les réserves notamment en
plaquettes et enclos globulaires nous
observons que les français ont très bien
compris qu'en cette période de crise
majeure
ils doivent donner ils peuvent donner
c'est à dire que là on a vu même des
nouveaux donneurs et merci à eux merci à
elle je crois que nous voyons apparaître
de nouvelles formes de solidarité il ya
des personnes confinées qui se disent
ensemble c'est le moment d'aller donner
son sang je n'ai jamais donné je vais
donner
vous savez que c'est une dérogation au
confinement et donc il y à de nouveaux
donneurs et de nouvelles donneuses et
tant mieux parce qu'effectivement on
voit bien que les besoins en sang sont
quotidiens il n'y a besoin de plus de
dix mille poches tous les jours et en
plus quand il ya beaucoup de personnes
en réanimation il peut y avoir des
besoins spécifiques liées la réanimation
donc si tu les personnes nouvelles
données si des personnes sont déjà
dehors de sang il faut continuer une
question pour hospimedia
l'association des accidentés de la vie
demande la création d'une commission
d'indemnisation disposant d'enfants
haddock
à l'image de l'oniam mais pour toutes
les professions concernées soignants
mais aussi personne mais personnels
médico-sociaux chauffeur policiers
caissière une telle commission est elle
envisagée je n'ai pas de réponse à ce
stade mais effectivement nous sommes
tous redevables de l'engagement de
l'ensemble de ces professionnels pour
combattre l'épidémie de question pour la
paix m
at on déjà pu observer les premiers
effets du confinement si oui lesquels
et à tour avancé sur la stratégie de
déconfinement une étude suggèrent qu'une
sortie de confinement en deux étapes
selon l'âge pourrait être préférable
vers quelles options s'oriente-t-on
alors premièrement l'évaluation du
confinement
comme je voulais déjà dit nous sommes un
peu plus de deux semaines cette
application du confinement
on va dire qu'on ait agi 16
de d'un confinement strict puisqu'il a
été total le mercredi est la première
une première paramètres compliment que
l'on peut observer c'est le recours à
sos médecins le recours à la médecine de
ville pour les personnes qui sont
malades et qui sont donc globalement en
deuxième semaine de leur évolution après
une semaine d'incubation
on voit aujourd'hui une baisse du
recours à essoyes ce matin c'est trop
tôt pour en tirer des conclusions mais
en tout cas c'est toujours une bonne
nouvelle qu'il y ait moins de recours
sos médecins pour une suspicion de go
vide
on ne peut pas analyser une situation
sur un chiffre est sur une journée mais
on est effectivement attentifs à cette
diminution est surtout si elle se
continue si elle se poursuit si nous
avons une consolidation de cette baisse
nous n'avons toujours pas de baisse en
réanimation je vous ai dit que
l'augmentation était un peu moindre mais
on a toujours besoin de davantage de
lits de davantage de deux équipes
mobilisées pour prendre en charge un
nombre toujours croissant de malades en
réanimation nous ne sommes pas du tout
encore au sommet de cette de cette vague
et encore moins à une un début de
décroissance de laval et puis ensuite
viendra le temps de la réflexion sur le
dé confinement qui sera de toute façon
complexe
le premier ministre l'a dit puisqu'il
faudra tenir compte des personnes les
plus fragiles comment est ce qu'on les
protège des personnes les plus âgées
comment est ce qu'on les protège des
spécificités régionales donc vous voyez
qu'il ya une réflexion très complexe à
mener pour que ce déconfinement se passe
dans les meilleures conditions
lorsqu'il sera décidée mais nous ne
sommes pas du tout là ce soir une
question pour politico les chiffres sur
les ehpad prend-il en compte les
personnels de santé et sinon vont y être
vont-ils y être intégrés pourquoi ne pas
transformer des arènes sportives en
hôpitaux de campagne au centre d'accueil
pour des soins pour effectuer des tests
par exemple alors plusieurs questions
sur sur les personnels de santé sont
testés là puisqu'ils sont prioritaires
là où l'on peut tester et donc ne sont
pas comptés dans l'établissement où ils
sont soit compté parmi les cas confirmés
qu'ils soient testés en milieu
hospitalier où est testée en ville
puisque les vous avez vu que laboratoire
de ville sont très fortement impliqué
c'est la même chose pour les personnels
des ehpad puisque l'on a de plus en plus
on encourage des équipes mobiles de test
les français le voient aussi de plus en
plus de laboratoires offre des tests
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
l'encouragent aussi que l'ensemble de
des parts des laboratoires dans tous les
départements puissent donner accès à des
tests quelle que soit l'activité du
laboratoire et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose que l'ensemble de nos
capacités de test en france soient
mobilisés pour renforcer cet accès aux
tests de diagnostic virologique
donc nous en sommes là ce soir ensuite
nous offrons une capacité de prise en
charge optimale dans l'ensemble des
établissements de santé je vous ai dit
que l'établissement de santé publique
étaient mobilisés que les établissements
de santé privés étaient mobilisés et
donc nous aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
de de besoin de créer des centres on va
dire de se situer de prise en charge
dégradée comme un stade comme un hangar
puisque nous nous hôpitaux peuvent
accueillant dans des conditions quand
même de sécurité optimales l'ensemble
des patients et là je tiens encore à
remercier les équipes soignantes les
équipes médicales les équipes
administratives qui ont réussi à doubler
cette capacité de réanimation ce n'avait
jamais été vu on n'a jamais eu autant de
malades en réanimation dans l'histoire
médicale française une question pour le
monde
de combien de jours de stock de propofol
et de curare la france dispose t-elle et
quelles sont les mesures concrètes
prises pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement de ces deux
médicaments alors nous sommes attentifs
à plusieurs sources de médicaments pas
uniquement ceux des médicaments nous
avez cité tous les médicaments
considérés comme d'importance vitale
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des
médicaments dérivés du sang médicaments
évidemment fondamentaux nous sommes
attentifs à l'accès aux curares à
l'accès aux anesthésiants à l'accès aux
produits de réanimation le premier
ministre a parlé de lattre à curium pour
lesquels nous nous étions assurés d'une
disponibilité de deux semaines pour dix
sept mille patients nous sommes aussi
attentifs avec l' agence européenne des
médicaments avec l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament à quelques
molécules très demandé dans la dans la
consommation explose actuellement le
site rah curium le midazolam le propofol
donc nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à ces tensions là nous
travaillons avec les professionnels pour
trouver des solutions nous travaillons
avec l'ensemble des pharmacies de
pour trouver les stocks puisque là
encore il peut y avoir des stocks dans
différentes cliniques qui utilise
notamment ses produits pour de
l'activité chirurgicale
donc cette activité étant
essentiellement aujourd'hui des
programmes et on peut encore trouver des
échanges entre pharmacie hospitalière
entre pharmacie en intra régional donc
toutes ces molécules font l'objet d'une
surveillance particulière
une sécurisation en amont d'une
discussion avec laboratoire de
mobilisation totale des laboratoires
mais aussi sur le terrain de partage
entre équipes et c'est là encore un beau
signe de solidarité plusieurs questions
de france 2 sur les ehpad
on a des remontées de 884 décès en ehpad
ces chiffres sont-ils confirmé quand
aurons-nous la totalité des remontées
des ehpad
alors c'est pas les chiffres que je vous
ai donné ce soir parce que je veux
donner beaucoup plus de décès puisque je
vous ai parlé des décès qui avait été
consolidée à date puisque nous avons
maintenant beaucoup plus d pad qui
signale ça veut pas dire que ces décès
sont survenus aujourd'hui mais je vous
ai parlé de 1417 1416 pour être précis
décès survenu en établissement de type
ehpad établissements médico-sociaux et
ça ce sont les déclarations de plus de
3000 établissements sur toute la période
qui court depuis le 1er mars jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc c'est là qu'ils
prouvent qu'il faut être attentif à
l'interprétation des chiffres puisque on
n'est pas passé de 800 à 1400
aujourd'hui mais bien que le chiffre de
1400 et consolidée sur toute la période
de l'épidémie est ce que les chiffres
des malades et des décès dans les soins
de suite et de réadaptation font partie
des chiffres donnés avec ceux des ehpad
non là aussi je vous dis tout dépend du
statut lorsque c'est une un service qui
dépend de la mettre dans un
établissement hospitalier c'est
l'hôpital et des glands une question
pour le généraliste
la hs invite les médecins à contacter
leurs patients chroniques les plus
fragiles pour éviter les ruptures de
soins
le ministère de la santé dispose t-il
d'indicateurs sur la mortalité indirecte
lyoko vie 19 et si oui avez-vous une
première estimation
non nous n'avons pas ces informations
nous espérons ne pas les avoir au sens
que nous n'espérons qu'il n'y ait pas un
seul mort qu'ils soient liés à perte de
chance ou de la part d'ailleurs du
malade souvent
ce que je leur dis peut-être pas assez
quand on a besoin de soins quand on est
suivi par un médecin spécialiste en
ville quand on est suivi à l'hôpital il
faut poursuivre ce suivi ne faut pas
avoir peur d'aller dans un centre de
dialyse dans un service de cardiologie
dans un service de néphrologie dont elle
s'habille de de prise en charge d'une
pathologie chronique parce qu'on a
besoin des deux suisses est donc
évidemment c'est une dérogation à la au
confinement si vous avez un rendez vous
si vous avez une bilan si vous avez un
acte de type dialyse à subir ou à de
nous devait bénéficier
c'est évidemment important de le
continuer et donc il y à un appel aux
malades chroniques un appel à une
personne qui ont besoin de soins de
prendre rendez vous avec leur médecin
s'assurer que les services qui les
suivent peuvent bien les suivre et puis
dans l'autre sens et c'est fait aussi
les services qui suivent des patients
chroniques les appelle pour dire
n'oubliez pas de venir à votre rendez
vous pour poursuivre le traitement pour
poursuivre les actes dont vous avez
besoin
une question pour cnn 350 passagers
américain d'un bateau de croisière ont
embarqué à bord d'un vol pour atlanta le
20 mars après avoir été testé au kovy 19
ans les autorités françaises les
résultats sont tombés pendant le vol et
trois passagers se sont avérés positifs
avez vous connaissance de ceux ci est
pourquoi les autorités françaises ont
elles laissé ses passagers montés à bord
alors je pense que c'est un rapatriement
d'un vol d'une perte de passagers qui
devaient venir d'un bateau donc ce sont
les autorités américaines qui ont
demandé le rapatriement de leurs
concitoyens ce que parfois les autorités
françaises font aussi donc nous testons
effectivement de nombreuses personnes et
quand nous testons et que nous avons des
résultats positifs et c'est valable sur
l'ensemble de la planète
il y à une transmission internationale
des données ça s'est vu depuis le début
d'épidémie entre l'asie et l'europe
entre l'europe et les états unis et donc
ça fait partie des bonnes pratiques
je vous remercie c'était la dernière
question